[Music]
today conspiracy TV MSNBC the liberal Jo
doubled down on stupid in his comments
about President Trump in 9/11 we've got
the evidence take a look
the retweeting of neo-nazi videos
Charlottesville I mean I could go on and
on what he said about majority black
countries that is tearing more at the
fabric of America then attacks on the
Twin Towers did we rebuilt from that we
became stronger because of that but this
is seems to me a far graver graver
threat to the idea of America joining us
now with reaction from the Trump
Organization the presidents from son
Eric trump go to see when your tomorrow
is your son's birthday congratulations
18 year I don't even know if I have a
lot more to say about Joe except it's so
cruel and so mean and so vicious even
for him
that and he took the time to write it
I've said dumb things and had to take it
back but it's we're not on a delay we're
life look how uncomfortable Willie guys
looked do you see him he said he just
wanted to you want bail out of there I
mean he was so uncomfortable but what a
stupid comment I mean what what about
believable stupid comment and sometimes
I watch the show and literally you
almost can't watch it's almost
unwatchable you end up turning it off
because it's crazy
9/11 was great strategy probably in the
history of this country you had 3,000
innocent people perished that day to
absolute savages horrible he compares
that to a man who gave up his life to
run for commander-in-chief to better
this country and by every economic
measure by every quantifiable measure
this country is doing better I don't
care if you look at unemployment if you
look at GDP growth if you look at stock
markets if you look at 401ks if you look
at the amount of people who have come
off food stamps I mean I could go on and
on on how about the largest tax cuts in
the history of this nation job is coming
back to his nation consumer confidence
being at an all-time high I mean I could
go on and on what kind of stupid comment
is this and it's it's quite frankly the
reason that Joe and mica have no
Watchers in the morning I mean watch
they have 500,000 how many people are
watching how much box of robots I don't
know yeah I mean it's really people
people are tired in this you know it's
just as a certain insensitivity mean it
but
like this is trunk trumped arrangement
you're right let's say that some people
don't like it that style that he fights
on Twitter that he takes on all comers
that he's combative he doesn't apologize
for things that the the political class
demands he apologizes for so what for me
we got 4 million more Americans working
we got 4 million fewer Americans on food
stamps all the things you talked about
more importantly heaps of word
conservative justices Supreme Court
fighting for the borders you know what I
would say not having a missile fired
over Japan since December is pretty
successful hostages home remains of
soldiers home thought that to me is and
everyone thought he'd start World War
three kind of worked out differently
better for the whole world
you know those savages that took down
the World Trade Center that flew a plane
into a field in Pennsylvania that flew a
plane in fish they are largely gone
because of the actions of my father over
the last 24 months
if you go back 24 months all you've
heard about Isis Isis Isis every day I
mean he put a war on them like they've
never seen before he unhandcuff the
military he let the guys who do the best
job in the world of brave men and women
go after these people go after these
savages and you don't hear about them
anymore they went for forty five
thousand soldiers on the battlefield the
heaviness heavies how about people off
of buildings how about ever they people
yet people do forget about that and it's
very sad and it was a stupid comment by
Joe one that obviously he instantly
actually doubled down on stupid and then
he got a lot of pressure then he kind of
pulled back halfway
look I don't call for boycott so I don't
want anybody to be silenced in the end
it's always conservative that they want
to silence he can say whatever he wants
and people have the power to watch or
not watch let me talk about these
elections in 56 days I keep saying it's
the most important midterm in our life
but the track record over a hundred
years it's only happened three times the
last time which it was George W Bush
after 9/11 that party comes to power in
the White House and they don't lose
seats and in the house will lose the
control of one of the chambers so hard
it's an uphill task yeah it might be but
but what are the Democrats message right
now let's raise taxes right that's one
of their message it avoids the crumbs
but let's raise taxes let's go after our
amazing law enforcement let's abolish
ice and whistle
Pratt plastic straws I mean then that's
literally the message of the Democrats
right now I mean they have no leadership
you saw the disaster that was the
Cavanaugh hearings where you have cory
booker bill o'hara seven hinged they're
up there grandstanding i mean the poor
guy didn't even get to speak for the
first seven hours of a hearing because
they're seeing they're going back and
forth running for president united
states up you know on the stage I mean
it's crazy I don't think America's into
that right you you look at how well the
economy is doing you look at how good
we've done for the point but you know
your dad's a charismatic guy a lot of
people voted for him in 2016 it's hard
to transfer charisma to some of these
candidates they suck I mean it
Republican that week they don't have a
backbone but they're not going to
impeach your dad
I believe Maxine Waters and Chuck
Schumer will reveal what their strategy
is they want their crumbs back they want
to rescind the tax cuts they don't want
conservative justices they want to
abolish ice as you said they want to
keep Obamacare name one thing that
they're offering the working men and
women in this country the Forgotten men
and women that's gonna make their lives
better and then Obama comes and takes
credit for it this week which is truly
shocking right I mean they all fought
against this tax cut that the greatest
tax cut in the history of the country
that puts so much fuel into our economy
and it's causing all these unbelievable
numbers that we're seeing every single
day with the atlanta's projector they
all voted against this projected 4:7 GDP
for the third quarter it's amazing and
by the way they had to revise GDP upward
support to this corner and do you
remember the New York Times in the LA
Times they all made fun of my father
during the election you know he says he
can get above 3% GDP there's no way he
can get above 3% GDP he's dreaming then
he gets 4.2 percent GDP and they're
crickets right they're talking about
Omarosa they're talking about some crazy
book that comes out this week I mean no
matter what he does they won't give him
credit and it's it's horrible but you
know what the people of these are pretty
calm about I'm not as calm as you people
of this country really smart they see
through nonsense they see through BS and
but 56 days if they want this to
continue then he's gonna yeah better go
out though but wait
by voting for Republicans you're helping
him succeed at the mission that you
elected in 2016 right and if you don't
you're effectively voting against him
but he's gonna do incredibly well he's
be keep waiting for this country and
them he's going again 2020 there are
missing for the new
like what who cares what I love my wife
won't let me shave haha thanks for
sharing
good to see you